and USA Today has a JD Power survey of
the best US airlines for 2018 the
rankings are based on seven categories
including cost in-flight services and
check-in Southwest Airlines earned the
top spot in the low cost carrier
category JetBlue Airways was number two
Alaska Airlines was number one among
traditional carries carriers rather for
the 11th year in a row Delta Airlines
came in second
Delta's recent investments include a new
look for its employees 64,000 Delta
workers debuted the collection of
uniforms yesterday it's one way that CEO
Ed Bastian is working to transform the
company Delta is also investing in major
renovations at California's LAX and New
York's LaGuardia airports under his
watch
Delta expanded its real-time bag
tracking program like that already this
year Fortune placed Bastion on its
world's greatest leaders list the
magazine noted the airline's
controversial decision to end an NRA
discount fortune called bastions
response a template for a well-reasoned
business leadership in a fragmented
world at Bastion joins us at the table
hello mister world's greatest leader
there are so many things to talk to you
about it but we just heard the JD Power
story where Alaska's number one Delta's
number two it's like that old commercial
if you remember Avis and Hertz Avis says
we're number two we try harder you are
not a number two guys so what are you
all doing well we continue to work hard
regardless of what JD power or anyone
says we think we are number one and we
continue to prove it you know we're a
global airline we operate in a little
different environment than Alaska Alaska
is a great airline too we give them we
give them kudos well we're really close
and we're gonna catch them one of these
days the average age of an Delta plane
is 17 years that's older than others
what is investing heavily mean it's not
the age of the plane that matters
because if you look at our reliability
statistics we're leading the industry by
a large measure across every every
dimension but what we're doing is we're
buying a lot of new planes we've got 65
new planes coming into the fleet this
year next year is going to be 85 Delta
was in the news recently you ended NRA
discounts after the parkland shooting
and then you flew some of the parkland
students to different rallies and you
said we're not taking sides this is not
a political decision but do the actions
indicate something otherwise
it does seem like a political decision
no it wasn't a political decision at all
when we saw the device of commentary
coming out of the NRA following the
shooting and we saw how our brand was
featured on their website because we
gave a relatively modest discount we
said we couldn't have her brand
affiliated with any organization that
had that level of divisive miss to with
the response to the shooting prior to
that even occurring we had immediately
reached out following the shooting to
the Parkland school as part as a
community outreach and asked the school
what can we do to help and what the one
things they said they could do the help
is help transport students so we had
already made that decision prior to the
NRA decision to take the kids up to the
rally to let them heal why did the NRA
have a discount to begin with do you
often give discounts to oh yeah we have
discounts for all sorts of groups and
what we've done is gone back and
reviewed our we're reviewing our policy
in any group that has a politically
divisive nature we're exiting those
types of relationships because our
branches doesn't need to be in a
political discussion what about the NRA
a response from NRA members what has
that been like well they were emotional
about it yeah but I can tell you on the
other side of that the the people that
had actually stood up and said Delta
thank you for sharing your values and
standing by your values because you've
probably heard there was money attached
to it Georgia State Legislature but
we're not the one for sale yeah it cost
you money cost us 40 million dollars a
year mm-hmm well that's because the
Georgia Legislature ended that discount
that fuel discount well they were going
to give us the discount and they decided
not to once they saw the the response
that we have looking at your first
quarter earnings Delta reported that the
market fuel cost rose 20% over the last
year is that ultimately going to be
passed on in terms of ticket fares well
it needs to you know it's the biggest
cost of businesses is fuel it's up 50%
on a year-over-year basis and so fuel
has moved a lot we're seeing that in the
news we're seeing Google to see the
impact of that in the economy I think
the current fuel environment may have
gotten a little bit overheated so we'll
see how that plays out even though
they're airline executives met with
President Trump at the White House what
did you want to tell him that that what
do you want from the administration to
improve that the experience in flying
well one thing that we wanted was
support from the government around the
Open Skies treaties we have some
middle-eastern carriers
that are subsidized by their governor
governments that we compete with
internationally and the administration
recently enacted some restrictions and
opened up discussions with the UAE and
Qatar to make certain that any flying
that they do in international
territories is not subsidized by their
government so we did receive some good
support there you know the other thing
we need going forward is that continued
support on the infrastructure side the
more we can get government support to
continue to make the investments it's
going to help all of us I think
yesterday's Starbucks had special
training for its employees you are in a
customer service business give us your
sense of Delta's role what more should
be doing what it does do in terms of
questions of implicit bias well we've
had all of our employees go through bias
training and we continue to focus on
that with respect to certainly we
carried 200 million people a year and
when you're out there as a public brand
and we are a public we're a lifestyle
brand you have to at all times
be aware of your environment not just in
the US on an international scale as well
we'll talk about that Delta rolled out
some new uniforms Zac Posen design
uniforms and with spans likely
partnership come about are you wearing
your Manx today no I have Spanx you
never has a Sarah I know Sarah hasn't
provided me my complimentary pair yet
now we had a wonderful rollout yesterday
I was with Sarah plum has more plum
color is the new hue we wanted to more
sophisticated looking you know one of
the things that we talk to our employees
and customers about is our uniforms
while they're very traditional and very
professional don't stand out they
couldn't identify that you the Delta
uniforms from the other competitors
because they all kind of were in the mix
so we're going international we've got a
more elegant sophisticated look no one
will miss the Delta people our Delta
people are great yeah when you put the
brand and the uniform together they were
they were stylish and I was flying
yesterday up here and the the
you know women that were wearing the the
new they they just they all look great
all right you look great too and Bastian
always good to have you thank you thank
you thank you